hello and welcome to this video yeah how
do you pronounce that bad ass probably
not anyway so what is he going to play
against my forehead a constant fence
okay you know the exchange variation is
a simple recipe for white you don't have
a huge advantage or anything but I think
it's quite comfortable let's see how he
handles at 96 Bishop f6 care those are
the normal moves played here
Yano 96 is common
hmmm it's taking a while you can also
play Bishop g4 of course
hmm that's odd it's a position that he
should have faced numerous times if he
plays this opening so what now if I
could Bishop is three there might be
Bishop to Knight to be fawn
maybe I made a wrong move over here it's
possible there should be three nights
before I cannot save my bishop that's
not good
can i play b3 here or is it wrong
b3 94-94 Bishop b4 bishop h7 as possible
you know maybe it's okay yeah now if I
go f3 I can do this dome yeah that
should it should be fine still my memory
water was probably not exactly precise
the night from c8 intends to regroup to
f5 okay so he basically states that
Queen d2 was not so great maybe I don't
have before now
[Music]
and you didn't really want to take but
maybe I have to judge do I get rid of
that piece 1g4 so now see one problem
9725 that's what what black wants to do
maybe I can put no okay neither to be 5
I wanted the same well here I have
Knight to e4 Knight e4 takes Queen
before there is 95 that is not really
what I want okay let's do this
maybe I get to play Knight h5 not even
have force possible right
and for f5 yeah but it does weaken his
pawn structure a little bit at least
maybe it's not a big deal that is that
is actually possible that this is not a
big deal for black because my bishop is
extremely weak on e3
Bishop is ready bad pizza
how do I play that after improve the
night my night on is this is really
really stupid piece but where where
should it go
g3 maybe in order to play queen d3
something like that
really Wow
that seemed like a really really
substantial strategic mistake I don't
believe this at all divorce week as well
right so I think it's a mistake to play
Bishop h4 in this position okay so me
what is he doing that he wants to play
before oopsy one book c5 would be really
nice
okay I have to secure my king first and
then see what what happens next that
also allows some additional things Queen
d3 for example but okay now I will go
look see one book c5 that would
definitely tie him a little bit the
knight is unstable on c6 yeah and if the
knight moves I can maybe regroup my
knight
it doesn't do anything there what
happens 135 I can't take you five it's
not like I cannot take it and at the end
he will take this I mean it cannot be
too bad
maybe it wasn't the best continuation
but it was okay I asked to take only two
there is no other move and now what's
best yet grab the beep on this is the
potentially most dangerous pawn that he
has so I'll take it
it's tough to activate my king it really
is tough maybe now I can actually do it
a little bit at least but he can still
continuously check me so it's going to
be almost impossible to do anything
there okay let's take this go here I
cannot activate the King unfortunately
it's there anyway he will continuously
check me but didn't really I cannot make
any progress here either
it's there anyway to know that it's true
yeah well I couldn't couldn't do much
him I will see but you cannot win
something there was just no way to win
this position
alright at least the game continues a
little bit still a complete draw
but I'm going to going to play on
well there is absolutely no risk here so
I can continue to play one
okay it's still a draw but you keep
wondering what he's doing them yeah and
it's drawn just probably fairies all
right maybe I had some chances I don't
know I don't really see a clear moment
where I could have improved so yeah I
wasn't really happy with taking the
engine that first up this doesn't mind
that at all yeah g 6f form is something
yeah it should be right I mean it's pawn
structure is really bad but my bishop is
also a real problem probably okay one
yahoo crook a three or a four is
suggested by the computer c5 or c5 is
interesting let's say damn okay probably
have to do something conservative
against this nerdy form something like
that is probably but this is equal and
so it's a really cool line this and then
it could be
Wow okay a rookie eight and then he
played this weird Bishop H form that's
really a strange move and it's even it's
endorsed by the engine I don't
understand chest
[Music]
yet here somewhere I thought I could
play for an advantage but it didn't work
out h3 King edge - I think was good and
I should play rook c1 immediately here
okay
the idea being okay I see if it takes
with the Queen I just move the Queen and
then get the pawn back that asset is
good yeah
no didn't see that well after this it's
extremely dry and I think it stays so
until the very end I don't think that in
this ending there was ever a situation
where somebody was better and see the
engine is on zero all the time so it
probably was always quite equal the ever
sent upon losses are very low I think we
played quite well then thanks a lot for
watching